Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome.
It is March 2023 and we're here in
ActInf Livestream 52.1.
Welcome to the Active Inference Institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning and
practicing applied active coherence.
This is a recorded and an archived
Livestream, so please provide us feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for livestreams head over
active coherence.org to learn more about
getting involved in learning groups and
projects such as live streams.
All right, we are in 52.1 and our goal
today is to learn and discuss this
awesome paper geometric Methods for
Sampling Optimization, Inference and
Adoptive Agents of Barp and Acosta at
all.
And we're going to just jump right in.
Thanks a lot Lance for joining and those
who have listened to 52.0 will know me.
I'm a researcher and learner with respect
to this topic.
So thanks again for joining and it'll be
great to have you introduce yourself and
also tell a little bit of the story of
how this paper came to be.
Lancelot Da Costa: Sure.
Thanks Daniel for organizing.
This is really great and I'm very happy
to be here.
So my name is Lance de Costa, some of you
may know me, I'm a PhD student both at
Imperial College of London and UCL,
mostly working on active inference and
the free energy principle.
Also some probabilistic machine
learning.
And today we're going to be discussing
geometric methods for sampling
optimization, inference and adaptive
agents.
So how this paper came to be where I
happen to know people in who do more like
statistics, machine learning and so on.
And we've always been talking about the
similarities and differences between what
we do in two inference and what they do
in sampling optimization, which are kind
of the workhorses of statistics and
machine learning.
And at some point we had a paper
invitation for the hamburger of
statistics and we decided to team up and
make a review article to see how all
these Fields that come from very
different places scientifically, that
have very different contributors as
well.
And we wanted to know how they're
interconnected and also how they can help
each other because we realized for all
this time that we're actually doing
similar things, but the communities are
very different, they're dot zero much
talking to each other.
And I think the main barrier is
difference in Lagrange, difference in
jargon.
So that was kind of an issue when we
started and so I wanted to put that all
as much as possible in a paper and see
how these different approaches to
statistics, whether it is sampling,
optimization, inference or decision
making, how they can benefit from each
other and how they relate to each other.
Long story short, we're going to delve
into this into more detail, but long
story short, if you want to ensemble from
a distribution, you can also view that as
an optimization problem.
So optimization is kind of you can see it
under the roots of sampling.
And you want to optimize sampling, make
sampling as efficient as possible
inference.
You can also see it as an optimization of
beliefs, optimization of probability
distinctions.
That's also an optimization procedure.
And if you want to do decision making,
which is what we do in active inference
and reinforcement learning and many
different places, well, through decision
making, you actually need optimization
and inference.
And if you want to do decision making
efficiently, you often are going to need
something as well.
So decision making, an active inference
is kind of like what comes at the very
end and requires all of the sophisticated
machinery of sampling coherence of
optimization in order to work.
So this was really the idea of the paper,
how does optimization come about, how do
you do efficient optimization?
And of course there's many different ways
to do that.
So we decided to focus on natural ways
and we'll get to that.
But one way to do optimization that is
very natural is through techniques from
geometry.
And so same with sampling.
In sampling and inference, you have
geometry that just comes up very
naturally when you want to solve these
problems.
And so decision making puts it all
together.
So that was really the idea of the
paper.
Can we put all these Fields together and
have a connecting line which is based on
geometry?
And so that's where we did.
Daniel: Awesome, great overview.
So, so many places to jump in.
I barely even know where to sample from
this distinctions.
Let's just start with sampling, though.
So what is sampling and how is it being
used?
How has it been used?
And let's characterize sampling and then
move on to these other Fields, right?
Lance: Well, sampling, I mean, the
idea of sampling is very simple and it's
also a very difficult thing to do.
So first explain the idea.
The idea is, let's say you have a
Bayesian in one dimension, so that's very
easy to picture.
Sampling would be so, for example, the
Gaussian I just mentioned describes the
temperature in the room.
So in my room, it's maybe currently 18
degrees Celsius, plus or minus some
variants representing my uncertainty.
Now, sampling from the distribution would
be saying it is maybe 19 degrees or maybe
17 degrees, drawing a lot of different
temperatures.
So that if you put them all together as a
histogram with their frequency, for
example, if you ask me what temperature
it is in my room, I would say there's a
higher chance that I say 18 degrees.
So I would say more often if you ask me
this question many times, and if you put
my answers, if you collect all my answers
in a histogram, for example, I'd say 18
degrees more often, so that barp around
18 degrees would be higher and the other
temperatures would be slightly lower.
And if you aggregate that, you would get
a Gaussian.
Get the Gaussian we started with.
So sampling, in other words.
And very simply, it's like drawing a data
point or an observation from an
underlying probability distribution.
You have a distribution, let's say a
Bayesian that represents your most likely
value of what the temperature in the room
is and some uncertainty.
And you just want to draw one or several
observations from that distribution.
And you want to draw these observations
so as to preserve the overall statistics
of the distribution that you started
with.
So that if you draw infinitely many data
points or infinitely many observations
from a distribution, then you can recover
the original distribution.
So that's what we want to do.
And so why is this useful in the first
place?
Well, it just happens all the time in the
things that you want to computer
integrals.
It just happens all the time.
So, for example, if you have a Bayesian
inference problem, you observe some data
in the world, it could be medical data,
it could really be anything, and you have
a prior and a likelihood of observing
that data.
So these are two terms in, like, Bayes
rule.
Then you want to know.
Then if you apply Bayes rule, you get a
posterior belief about what caused that
data that you observed.
So, for example, a practical use case
would be some medical data of a patient
that's sick, and you want to know.
So you get, for example, it's blood
pressure, collection of symptoms and so
on.
So that's your data, and you want to know
what kind of disease or what kind of
function caused that data.
So let's say typically you would have a
model of, if I have this malfunction of
this disease, I would have these
symptoms.
If I have this other disease, I would get
these other symptoms.
And so Bazrul enables you to infer in the
best way possible, the disease that
caused the symptoms that you just saw.
So this is like a common thing, something
that people use every day in statistics
all the time, and arguably everybody uses
it every day because the thesis of the
Franca principle, or the result that it
provides, is that you can describe
exteroception of humans as doing basic
inference.
So basic inference is a very ubiquitous
thing.
You can use it to describe perception in
humans, and you can also use it to do
statistics and solve all kinds of
problems.
So, coming back to sampling, actually
doing Bayesian inference, you have this
problem of how do you compute the
posterior distribution in the first
place?
And it turns out that this distinctions
is generally intractable because you have
kind of a term in the denominator that's
very hard to compute.
And so one ways to compute it is to use
what's called Monte Carlo methods.
And Monte Carlo methods are based on
sampling.
So, long story short, in order to do
Bayesian inference, you need to compute
this, like, log likelihood term, which is
a high dimension integral and one way to
do it is by using Monte Carlo methods.
And Monte Carlo methods are based on
sampling.
So the sampling enables you to
approximate the high dimensional integral
they started with.
So now many listeners, or also the
readers of this work will wonder, well,
one thing that people do in the free
hundred principle and also kind of like
the red on that of the 300 principle, is
you're actually not going to compute this
denominator.
That's very expensive to the Bayesian
inference, but you're going to
approximate the posterior by minimizing
free energy, which is called variational
inference.
That's another method of doing Brett and
coherence and it has many advantages over
sampling.
Sampling also has advantages with respect
to variational inference.
We can get into that.
So if that's what you're thinking, well,
this is not necessarily interesting
because we can do variational coherence.
There's so many other places where we
need sampling in statistics.
I would say basically anytime you need to
compute an integral and integral are all
over the place.
But I think the Bayesian inference
implication is a nice one because it just
speaks to all of us.
So how does actually sampling getting to
the picture of integration?
Let's say we have an integral that we
need to compute.
An integral is basically, let's say you
have a state space.
So to be very simple, let's say the state
space is my desk.
It would be like a planner surface and we
have a function that's defined on the
desk.
So this would be like a landscape over
the desk, right?
Like a 2D surface landscape that could be
rocked or whatever.
The integral of this function is going to
be the volume between the landscape and
the desk.
This is kind of like the geometric
picture of what an integral is.
This turns out to be very hard to compute
in practice because let's say you have a
very rough surface and it's not clear how
to compute all this volume, which is very
irregular.
What sampling does is it's going to pick
a few locations on the desk, as many as
you wish.
So let's start by one.
And it's going to compute the height
under the function and then pick another
location and compute that height as well,
since sampling is going to pick locations
on the desk at random.
And from there it's going to build a
histogram that's going to approximate the
surface that you started with.
And so histogram is very simple because
you get a whole bunch of skyscrapers if
you wish to approximate the surface that
we started with.
And computing the volume of skyscrapers
is very simple because they're like
squares.
It's like depth times height times
width.
It's very simple to compute the volume of
those things.
So this is kind of the idea we want to
computer the volume under a rock
surface.
And to do that, we're going to pick
arbitrary locations on the desk, on the
page space and build it.
And at those locations build like
skyscrapers at the height of the
surface.
So you get like a skyline, a histogram
that approximates your original
function.
And it's very simple to know the volume
of the histogram, the volume of the
skyline.
So from then you get an estimate of the
integral that you started with.
So that's kind of like the geometric
picture.
The beauty of this is that it works in
the arbitrary dimensions and it doesn't
suffer from the curse of dimension.
So this is why it's so powerful, if you
want to know.
So there's a formula that tells you how
well the volume of your skyline will
approximate the volume of the volume that
you initially wanted to compute the
integral.
So this difference between the integral
and your estimate basically decreases as
a function of the number of skyscrapers
that you put in.
The more skyscrapers, the more precise
you get.
And this bound on the error that you have
on your integral that you started with,
it doesn't depend on the dimension.
So as the higher dimension on your state
space.
So let's say let's imagine I had a high
dimension desk, which is very hard to
imagine, and I had a function on top of
it, and I wanted to compute the area
under the function.
If my desk was very high dimensional, the
higher the dimension, the harder it would
be to solve this problem numerically.
But with sampling, actually, the degree
of accuracy that you get through sampling
would be agnostic to the dimension.
This is why it's so powerful and just
used all the time in physics and machine
learning.
When you imagine practical problems that
you have in machine learning, going back
to medical data, you could get a whole
bunch of data about a patient, which
could be heart rate over time, blood
oxygen levels, blood glucose levels, body
temperature and whatnot.
There's so many data modalities that you
would have.
So your state space would have many, many
dimensions.
And also the state space of the different
diseases that could have given rise to
all these symptoms would be also very
high.
So it could be that the patient has
fever, or it could be that it has flu.
Fever is a symptom.
It could be that the disease is flu.
It could be that the disease is
tuberculosis.
It could be that the disease there's so
many different conditions or problems
that one might want to examine.
So in this particular case of medical
data, and this is just like a very simple
use case, I would say you have a very
high dimensional state space.
And to debate an inference, you have a
very high dimensional integral to
estimate.
And so one way to do that efficiently, or
maybe efficiently, is disingenuous
because it's just very hard.
I mean, it's just very computationally
intensive to do these things.
But one way to do this, that state of the
art, is through sampling just by drawing
different points at random on this safe
space and approximating the functional
landscape and approximating the integral
like that.
So, yeah, this is really why this is so
important.
Daniel: Awesome.
So we've made a sample where does these
topics of accepting or rejecting a move
amongst examples or discretizing, how do
we pick that next sample?
And then what does it mean to accept or
reject that sample?
Lance: That's a great question.
This is basically like the heart of
sampling.
If you knew how to do that in full
generality, sampling would be sold, which
it isn't.
So I'm going to tell you a bit like where
things stand.
To do sampling, you need to pick places
at random and you need to pick places at
random.
So that's to preserve probability
distribution.
So going back to the example of the desk,
you want to pick in that case, you want
to pick examples uniformly on the desk.
If we come back to the previous example
of like a Gaussian distribution, you want
to pick samples that preserve the
Gaussian distribution.
So you ant to preserve to take a lot of
samples around the mean very few samples
on the tails.
So it turns out that for those very
simple distributions like uniform
distribution, Galveston distribution,
there are ways to sample that do not
require what this paper is talking
about.
So there are ways to sample exactly that
do not lead to any kind of error and that
are very fast.
So for Gaussians and uniform and a bunch
of other distributions from the
exponential family, you have ways to
sample.
Exactly.
So the problem is these distinctions,
they're not there all the time.
And it turns out that very often you
don't have these kind of very simple
distributions, otherwise we would be
done.
So one simple example coming back to
Bayesian inference is the idea of
Jeffrey's Prior.
So Jeffrey's Prior is the idea that you
should take the highest entropy prior
that's consistent with what you know
about the system.
Why entropy maximizing?
So we know that entropy is a measure of
the uncertainty present in the
distribution.
And so what Jeffrey's Prior says is that
you should take a prior belief about a
system, the belief that is maximally
uncertain, uncertain, but that is also
compatible with your knowledge.
So out of all priors that are compatible
with what you know about the system, you
would take the one that's most
uncertain.
And this seems pretty intuitive, right?
So when you take Jeffrey's Friar, what
you get is often a distribution that's in
the form of what people call a Gibbs
measure.
So Gibbs measures or Gibbs distributions
there of the form exponential minus V.
So they're like proportional to
exponential minus V, and V could be an
arbitrary function.
So just as an example, if V were like a
parabola, a quadratic function, then the
associated Gibbs distribution is a
Gaussian.
So we all know what Gaussians are,
right?
But v could be pretty much anything.
If you take V to be like X to the power
of four minus X to the power of two, then
V is kind of like a camel upside down.
So, you know, it has like two humps.
And therefore the exponential minus V
distribution, the Gibbs measure, would be
like a gaussian, but with two humps.
So these gibs measures, they're just
there like everywhere and they come up
all the time.
So one other example is in statistical
mechanics.
So let's say you have a system of
molecules that just interact with each
other, and this system of molecules, they
could also be subject to thermal
fluctuations.
And whatnot this system is going to relax
to what people call a steady state, often
a non equilibrium steady state.
These steady states, which is kind of
like the end configuration of the system,
is in general a gives measure.
Now, you can see that in statistical
mechanics and also in statistics, gives
measures come up also in basic
inference.
And it's very hard in general to sample
from a gives measure.
There's ways to do it and we're going to
come back to it, but we need to solve
this problem.
It's a very important problem.
And so the most common way to solve from
this distribution is what's called Markov
Chain Monte Carlo.
The idea is to run a Markov chain.
So to run like a stochastic process.
And you could think of it as stimulating
molecules that interact with each other
with some thermal fluctuations and that
are going to relax to this gift
distribution, this steady state that you
originally specified.
So coming back to the original examples,
the steady state could be like a gaussian
they want to sample from.
Coming back to the example of the desk.
It could be the uniform distribution on
the desk that we want to sample from.
It could also be a gift measure.
So once we know the distribution that we
want to examples from, we're going to
design a stochastic process, some kind of
random motion whose distribution is going
to converge to the target distribution.
So as you run the process, think of it as
simulating those molecules that interact
and that converge to your target.
You're just going to simulate that.
And once your system has converged to its
steady state, which is the target
distribution, then each movement on the
steady state density is going to give you
a new sample.
Just for intuition, let's come back to
the desk and say that we have this
uniform measure, uniform distribution on
the desk that we want to sample from.
So we're going to design like a dynamic
that moves randomly around and that's
going to concept to the uniform
distribution, which means that if you run
it long enough, you're just going to
sample everywhere on the desk and it's
going to examples each point equally
often.
And so you're just going to run this
dynamic for a very long time and then
you're going to collect the samples,
collect the examples and use them to
approximate the integral that you started
with.
So this is how sampling is done.
Now, there's two basically one big
question, one big outstanding question is
how do you choose this dynamics?
How do you choose this random motion to
converge to your target distinctions to
sample from the distribution?
So given a target distribution there's
like a closed form formulas for all the
possible choices of processes that you
can use to sample from them.
That's a closed problem and that's also
explained in the paper.
But then out of all of these processes
you would like to know which one is going
to sample the most efficiently and you
also want to know.
And second of all, a lot of the analysis
of stochastic processes is done in
continuous time.
So you know that if you implement this
process it's going to converge at this
rate to the target distinctions.
And so the faster it converges, the
better.
But it could be that when you simulate
this on a computer, in a computer you can
only have like discrete time steps or
like discrete operations in discrete
time.
So you cannot really simulate this
dynamic in continuous time.
So every time you simulate it, it's going
to introduce some error.
Now it could be that the thing that you
simulate on your computer actually goes a
lot slower than the original process that
you wanted to simulate.
So there's these two questions.
How do you take a process that samples
very efficiently, converges very fast to
your target?
But in addition to that, how do you
stimulate the process accurately on your
computer so that's to retain all the
important characteristics of that
process?
So there's many different criteria and
this is what we discussed essentially one
method that state of the art or among the
state of the art is called Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo.
Now, Hamiltonian Monte Carlo, without
getting Hinton too much detail, it has
two advantages.
The first advantage is that it can be
analyzed using mathematical methods.
So you can get guarantees based on your
target distribution.
You can get guarantees of how fast you're
going to converge, how accurate your
samples are, gain to be and so on.
It has also many other desirable
properties.
So one of them which we discuss a lot in
the paper is the importance of being
irreversible.
So irreversible means being irreversible
means that if you run the process forward
in time let's say you run the process
forward in time for like 10 seconds.
Let's say you run the process backward in
time.
So you kind of run the process backward.
You just take a movie and play it
backward and look at how the process
behaves.
Now, a process is reversible if the
forward and the Ballard movies are
statistically indistinguishable and a
process is irreversible if you run time
as time goes forward.
If you run time forward, it would look
statistically different from if you run
the process backward.
I think you can kind of picture what
irreversibility is.
Now, irreversibility is crucial to do
efficient sampling because if you're
reversible, it means that you're going to
backtrack.
Very often when you're sampling positions
on the decks, on the desk, say you're
going to start somewhere, go somewhere
else, and then there's a nontrivial
chance, significant chance that you're
going to come back to where you started.
So it's going to be very slow to explore
all the desk and build skyscrapers
everywhere.
So then sampling turns out to be very
slow.
Now, when you're irreversible, there's
way less chances that you just come back
to where you started.
So you're going to explore the desk a lot
faster because you're not allowed to come
back to the same place so much.
And so you're going to assemble faster
and it's going to be much more
efficient.
So it's actually, by going from a
reversible process for sampling to an
irreversible process, you can gain orders
and orders of magnitude, efficiency.
It's actually pretty crazy.
The Hamiltonian monte Carlo has
guarantees.
Is irreversible.
It has other desirable properties.
And the main one is that you can actually
stimulate it on a computer in a way that
the discretized version, which you
actually simulate on the computer is
going to be very close to the true
Hamilton in Monte Carlo that you get by
writing the equation down.
So this is like why it's so big and why
people use it.
Yeah, I think this is pretty much it.
Hamiltonia Monte Carlo has an accept
rejects step, which is coming back to
when you simulate a process on your
computer.
Every time you discreditize a process,
you introduce some error.
Now you want to make that discretization
error as small as possible so that the
process that you actually simulate on
your computer is very close to what you
want to simulate.
So Hamiltonia Monte Carlo has a very
important step called Metropolis
Hastings, which is going to say, should I
keep the sample or should I drop the
sample and go to the next examples?
And by using Metropolis Hastings, it's a
very clever but also simple procedure.
By using Metropolis Hastings, you
guarantee that the distribution that
you're going to sample is exactly the
same as the distribution that you want to
sample.
So just to put in other, maybe simpler
terms, so you have this process that you
want to simulate.
This process is going to sample your
target distribution.
Now, it could be that when you discrete
the process, because the discrete process
is different, you're going to sample from
a slightly different distinctions.
Now, by using Metropolis Hastings, you're
going to guarantee that the distribution
that you sample from in practice is
exactly the same as what you really want
to sample from.
And so that's very important because it
just tells you that asymptotically as the
number of examples just growth to
infinity.
You're going to recover exactly what you
wanted to recover, which is the adamant
shrine to grow.
Daniel: Awesome.
I remember the Metropolis Hastings and
the Monte Carlo Markov chains in
phylogenetics where you might have many,
many species and many, many locations in
the genome that you're doing phylogenetic
inference over and you just sample,
sample, sample.
And so all these techniques help
accelerate what's possible with any given
computational hardware.
So how would you bring this towards
adaptive agents?
Are we thinking about this sampling
process as being guided by an adaptive
agent and or are we sampling
distributions about an adaptive agent?
Lance: That's a great question.
And I think it sort of brings us to the
conclusion of this work.
In order to have adaptive agents and to
scale adaptive agents so that they're
able to solve complex problems and you're
able to implement them with finite
computational resources, one useful tool
is sampling.
And we'll see many different places where
sampling can be used and has been used in
active inference.
And that's basically what you said
sampling is at the heart of sampling is
choosing data points intelligently so as
to approximate your integral or whatever
it is that you want to do with those
samples.
So you could think of active agents as
solving the sampling problem.
You could think of an active inference
agent.
Let's say that you have a problem of
sampling.
You could think of an agent, an active
inference agent that's going to choose,
oh, I'm going to sample here, and I'm
going to sample here, and I'm going to
sample here.
So active inference agent in the proper
sense of the word.
They do sampling all the time.
The only I would say, slight difference
with what we've just discussed is that
active inference agents, they sample
observations so that they comply with
their preferences and they observations
that also bring them new information
about the world.
So the objective that active inference
agents use to select new sample is the
expected free energy.
Typically we select actions or policies
that have the lowest expected free
energy, which means that the resulting
observations will be close to your
preferences or goal and also bring you
new information about the world.
But you could also conceivably think of
an agent as selecting actions so that the
resulting samples or observations
accurately sample a distribution.
So how could sampling be used in the
context active coherence lab and adaptive
agents?
And so this is actually a great slide, if
you look at the upper panel is what I
just discussed.
So in the first equation that's up there,
you see that the sequence of actions that
you chaos in active inference is the one
that minimizes this minus lot T, this
probes distribution over action
sequences.
So this minus lot T is actually the
expected free energy.
So we choose action sequences that mean
by the expected free energy, as you see
on the equation just below the expected.
Free energy is a sum of risk and
ambiguity.
So you're going to choose action
sequences that minimize risk, but that
also minimize ambiguity about the world.
And in other words, as shown below,
you're going to choose action sequences
that maximize extrinsic value.
So you could think of that as an expected
reward and intrinsic value.
So that would be expected information
gain value that's intrinsic because
you're getting information.
So really the key here is that this
expected free energy, as its name
suggests, it's given by an expectation.
So you see this minus lock p on the left
equals expectation of something.
Now, when you have a very big generative
model, a very big world model, which is
going to be the case all the time, when
you have, like, a real world application
or a complex application, because the
world around us is so high dimensional,
so complex, well, the expected energy
then is going to be a high dimensional
expectation.
What is an expectation?
It's an integral with respect to
probability distribution.
So the point I want to get to is that to
do decision making, you need to evaluate
the expected free energy on different
action sequences.
And this expected free energy is an
expectation with respect to probability
distribution.
It's a very high dimensional integration
problem, very high dimension integration
expectation.
And so how do you approximate that while
you use template?
And I think the first work that actually
used that in the context of active
inference is the work by Fuentes et al.
2020.
I think it's called scaling active
inference with Monte Carlo methods.
So this is what they did.
I think it was published in New Ritz.
It's a very big machine learning
conference.
And their observation was, okay, well, we
have this active inference method which
theoretically is very powerful, I mean,
in the sense that you have this expected
free energy objectives, that puts a lot
of known constructs together.
So the expected free energy, as shown in
figure three here, puts together this
risk.
So this is the divergence between your
predicted distribution of where you're
going to be in the world and your target
distribution of where you want to be in
the world.
And it has this ambiguity term as well,
which has some nice links with phenomena
in psychology, like the streetlight
affect.
So when you minimize we introduce actions
that minimize ambiguity.
You can recover phenomenology that's
known in psychology, like the streetlight
affect or the drunkard search.
Risk is also an objective that's used in
engineering, in controller inference.
So you can see it on the left panel.
So there are a few methods for doing
adaptive agents that use this KL term.
One would be controlled coherence, which
is also known as maximum entropy
reinforcement learning and KL control.
And also, I think, although it needs to
be investigated further, it hasn't been
formally, I think, so far, but with the
KL turn there, you can recover
predictions that are made by prospect
theory which is a big theory from the end
of the 20th century about decision making
in human agents.
So this is, I think, worthwhile to look
into further but I think there's some
very clear links between that theory and
the scale term in the expected franca.
Anyway, so you have this expected free
energy objective that's very powerful.
Chaos puts a lot of things together.
So I think theoretically it's very nice.
In the last line of the upper panel you
can also see that you can view expected
PNG as weighing expected reward and
expected information gain, extrinsic
value, intrinsic value and extrinsic
value.
It's used in expected utility theory,
basic decision theory, RL, optimal
control.
So these are all like equivalent names
for maximizing this extrinsic value and
intrinsic value, expected information
gain.
It's also used in different places and
for example in Bayesian experimental
design which is in statistics.
It was a seminal paper by Lindley in 1956
and Lindley basically said, okay, well,
suppose that you you can do two
experiments or many different
experiments.
How should you choose between them?
What's the best experiment that you
should do?
And the answer that he came up with is
you should do the experiment that gives
you the most information about the
world.
So you have to keep in mind that in that
paper there was no extrinsic goal.
It was not like we're going to do an
experiment to solve this problem or
achieve these results.
It was only doing an experiment for the
sake of it.
And so he came to the conclusion that the
best experiment was the one that
maximized the expected information gain.
Now suppose that you have a goal in mind
target, target result or whatnot then you
would weigh reasonably and one thing you
could do is weigh the expected
information gain with your expected
reward or expected utility or expected
how close you're going to get to your
goal.
And so this is exactly what the expected
free energy does.
It puts these two things on the same
footing.
So you have this expected free energy
which is very nice and which is what
active inference brings to the table and
what Fuentes et al did in their paper is,
okay, well, we have this cool method,
active inference, let's use it to solve
nontrivial machine learning, slash
reinforcement learning problems.
And so when you actually want to solve
those problems you have some high
dimensional generative models, high
dimensional state spaces that just come
up and you need time plane to evaluate to
approximate the expected principle.
So this is what they did and they also
put together a lot of other cool tricks
based on neural networks and so on.
So a very cool paper, totally recommend.
But I think the point it suggests, and
this is also the point that we make,
although in a very different way in this
paper is that to actually do decision
making efficiently in practice
efficiently.
But also you want to do take good
decisions.
You actually need sampling.
And this is not a new point, by the way.
I think many people would agree with
this.
But I think the active inference approach
is nice because you have this explicit
characterization of expected PNG as an
expectation of something.
So it becomes pretty clear that you want
to do sampling because this is what
sampling is made for.
So I initially introduction sampling as
you know, wanting to approximate
integral, but expectations are integral.
So yes, sampling is really what you
want.
It just comes up like extremely directly
when you want to do these kind of
things.
Awesome.
Daniel: Thanks.
And one sensory example of information
driven sampling is the eye circade the
movement of the eyes, which also has been
modeled in many works from the active
inference perspective.
And it's even below our level of
conscious awareness with the eyes darting
around to reduce their uncertainty such
that our visual generative model can have
high resolution and color throughout the
visual field, even though that doesn't
reflect the anatomy of the retina, which
has a blind spot and differential
resolution and color attention in the
periphery.
So I kind of see that as slam dunk
evidence that our visual experience and
by extension other sensory modalities are
coming from the generative model.
They're not just received and processed
in an inward bound fashion and that
adaptive sampling is vital to maintain
the coherence of that generative model.
Lance: Absolutely.
You want to do adaptive sampling in order
to preserve the structure.
I mean, you have this beautiful structure
in the expected free energy of expected
information gain.
So let's say we're just like wanting
we're just like looking at stuff, so we
don't have any direct goal.
The expected energy reduces to expect
information gain or approximates that and
you just want to sample sampling is the
key to approximate this expected
information gain term while preserving
the statistics of the generative model.
So it's very central to scaling active
coherence.
I wouldn't say it's central, active
inference lab proper just the theory
because in the theory you get these
expectations and you know how to select
actions.
But anytime you want to scale active
coherence, deploy active inference to
solve a problem you want to, sampling is
going to come into play inevitably.
There's other ways to scale active
inference.
One other way could be what's called
amortizing.
Amortization.
So with deep neural networks.
So one thing you could do is train a
neural network to predict the expected
free energy based on your genital model
and near sensory data.
But this amortization procedure, as does
any training of neural networks, it's
going to require a lot of data.
So it's going to be slow.
It's not something that you can deploy
right away.
So this is very nice way of I mean,
amortization is a very nice way of doing
things, but it's not something that you
can use like the first time you active
inference lab to solve a new task.
So a nice way of scaling active coherence
and it's not the only way, or it's not
going to solve all the problems, but it
would be to use sampling to approximate
the expected free energy to make
decisions in real time as you accumulate
data, then you can train a neural network
to predict the expected free energy.
I think this is exactly what Fuentes et
al.
Did in their paper, by the way.
So if you're interested, make sure to
check it out.
Daniel: Figure three.
It's something that Vaughn can just look
ant for so long, because the imperative,
what is being utilized in action
selection by an active inference agent is
something like a generalization of all
the words that we see written lower.
And unless we knew about that
generalization or that unified
imperative, it seems like these are quite
literally orthogonal or disparate from
each other.
I mean, what could be more different than
maximum information, gain oriented
strategies and maximum reward driven
strategies?
And sometimes to get both those flavors
in the same model, people might try to
coerce one into the other.
Usually we see that in terms of a novelty
bonus or an exploratory impulse bolted on
to a reward or a pragmatic value driven
agent.
And so once you start modifying the
models and just adding in these
arbitrarily constructed components, you
may get adaptive behavior.
It's never been a claim in the active
space that other models don't have
efficacy.
Rather that by thinking about all of
these special cases as being
situationally arising from a more general
imperative with expected free energy for
future oriented policy selection, we
might gain the ability to do what?
What will we gain conceptually or in
practice by taking situations where today
people are using maybe just one of these
terms as an imperative for what their
models are doing and what do we gain or
what might we expect from potentially
generalizing those imperatives?
Lance: That's a brilliant and very
difficult question.
It's also a question that I would say
everybody active coherence lab gets asked
at some point because, let's say people
doing reinforcement learning, they use
many different objectives that would be
tailored to solving one particular task
or a different task, and they would have
these ad hoc novelty bonuses that would
work very well in certain tasks.
It's a different approach.
This approach that I was just mentioning
with reinforcement learning tests to be
it's much more bottom up.
It's like we want to have an agent that
solves this problem, makes this work, and
so on.
So we're going to start building and test
it until it works.
Active inference lab approach is top
down.
So it starts from the furniture principle
and it's very theoretical.
And the approach is like, okay, well,
let's model how an agent interacts with
its environment, the force generic kind
of agent, and let's impose constraints
that an agent has to satisfy.
So the basic constraint that we have in
this paper is that you have three sets of
variables.
You have variables in the external world
that you cannot directly have access to.
So this would be maybe the temperature in
the room.
Then you have sensory variables or
observations.
So by the way, the environmental
variables that are denoted as S, the
sensory observations, are the observatory
or the observations that are denoted as
O.
So this is what belongs to the world and
you have direct access to this would be
like your sensations, what you see and so
on.
And then you have the action denoted in
the paper by A, which is basically what
you can do, and the different things, the
different options that you can choose
from at any point in time.
And this is what will enable you to
influence the world S and influence your
observations.
O.
So we start from a very generic model of
an agent and how it interacts with the
world, these three sets of variables that
evolve in time and just by adding a few
other, I would say, constraints that
agents satisfy, or intelligent agents
hopefully satisfy, that these agents can
be described as taking decisions that
minimize expected free energy.
So the expected free energy just comes up
from this general theory of how agents
behave.
So to answer your question, what does
this actually bring in practice?
Well, first of all, there's many methods
out there that are similar to active
inference.
In some cases, they're almost the same.
The first difference, which is not
necessarily an advantage or a
disadvantage, but it's the approach.
These are the methods that you see out
there that come very close to active
inference.
They have been designed from a bottom up
approach of like, we want to model this
system or we want to solve this task, so
we're going to add all the components
that are needed until our agent does what
we want it to do.
And it turns out that sometimes all these
ingredients turn out to be exactly what
we get.
Active Inference lab or very similar.
Other times, maybe the task would be
simpler and you would get less
ingredients.
The disadvantage of that, I would say, is
that it can turn out to be very messy.
So you get a new task or a new thing to
model, maybe a new paradigm that some
subject would do, and you end up using a
very different model, a very different
objective to describe the behavior at
hand.
So it's harder to have like a unified
perspective of what's going on.
Active Inference I would say the key
contribution is that you get this unified
perspective from it.
You get this objective that puts together
a lot of other constructs that we know
and love and puts them together.
And you know that with this objective you
can do a lot of things, which is, for
example, decision making that weighs
exploration and exploration.
Now, there are some challenges with
active inference and anybody using active
inference would be familiar with them.
The first one is the scaling up because
you have this approach, active inference,
which is so complex in a way.
I mean, you need to have a generative
model of the world.
You need to have to be able to compute
all these expectations.
First of all, you need to be able to
compute all these posterior distributions
using bayes rule or variational
inference.
Then once you have those posterior or
approximate posterior distributions based
on your high dimensional model of the
world, then you need to compute some
expectations, very high dimensional
expectation using sampling or whatnot, to
then get the expected free energy.
So the expected free energy doesn't come
up for free.
It's actually a very I would say it's a
quite sophisticated thing.
It puts all these things together, but it
doesn't come for free.
It's hard to implement on a practical
problem that's nontrivial beyond toys and
nations and people have done it, but it's
a challenge.
So the problem that active coherence has
is, okay, well, we have this night
theory, we have this very nice objective
that theoretically works very well, and
theoretically it's like or it's similar
to what you would like to have for any
kind of agenda.
But we need to find ways of scaling this
up.
Here comes the beauty of this, is that in
scaling up active inference, you're going
to use sampling, you're going to use
techniques from optimization, from
coherence, and so you're going to get
something that's slightly different from
the active inference scheme that you
started with.
So you had the active inference scheme
proper, which was in the picture in the
previous slide.
This is active inference as you would
like to implement it if you could.
But because the problem is complicated
and you have a high dimension state,
space and so on, you have many things
that are computationally intensive,
you're going to use something, you're
going to use optimization, you're gain to
use inference, and so you're going to get
something.
Active inference lab algorithm that
scales, but that's slightly different
from what you started because it has all
these other steps.
Now, in doing so, the active coherence
agent becomes engineered.
So it becomes closer to these
reinforcement learning and bottom up
agents that are built in a bottom up way
to solve certain tasks.
Because you want to engineer the active
impress algorithm to be able to work to
solve a certain problem, to scale it in a
certain way.
So in doing so, active imprint becomes
closer to reinforcement learning.
Now, conversely, in reinforcement
learning, the amount of compute is
increasing.
People want to build reinforcement
learning agents that are increasingly
learn in an unsupervised manner just
because this scale is better.
You can't always design all the
components of your reinforcement learning
agent to solve any single tax.
It's just too impractical, especially
when tasks become more and more
complicated.
You just would like general solutions
that are going to work and are going to
handle a lot of different types of
situations.
So reinforcement learning is adding or
subtracting ingredients to their
algorithms.
All these algorithms are evolving.
But in some sense you can see this is
debatable, I suppose, but you can see a
general tendency towards moving to world
models and generative models, moving to
intrinsic motivation, which is another
word for expected information gain or
variants thereof, and an intrinsic
motivation or intrinsic value that's
added onto extrinsic value which is your
expected reward.
So you see many I mean, I think we're
seeing reinforcement learning evolve in a
direction also that is closer active
inference lab because everybody wants
algorithms that stole different tasks and
not to have to change the algorithms for
changing environments and so on.
So in my view, even though we started
with two different approaches, a bottom
up approach and a top down approach,
these are converging.
Now to come back to the contribution of
active inference, if one reads through
the paper and one looks at the derivation
active inference lab, the point is that
it's very agnostic.
It's agnostic to the environment that
we're in.
It's an agnostic to many things.
So it's very general.
And so if you take many practical
reinforcement learning agent, you will
see that they interact with their
environment in a way that's compatible
with the assumptions of the free hundred
principle.
In other words, the reinforcement
learning agents can be recast as specific
active inference agents with specific
giant models.
So this is really the key thing.
It's this unifying perspective.
I'm not saying it unifies everything, but
I'm saying that many different
reinforcement learning algorithms can be
recast as active inference agents.
And so this is not to say that active
inference lab implementation of those
reinforcement algorithms is going to be
better, but it's more like a theoretical
contribution of like this set of
equations given by the expected primary
is a complete recipe or almost complete
recipe to generate adaptive agents.
So in some sense you don't have to go any
further than that.
And so you can view all these
reinforcement learning algorithms that
comply with the assumptions so that can
be recast as active inference algorithms
as ways of scaling active inference and
making active inference work.
So it's not like I don't see any kind of
conflict between active inference and
reinforcement learning, but it's more
like the reinforcement learning
algorithms that work well and that can be
recast as active inference algorithms.
And there are many, I would say more
algorithms that can be recast and
algorithm that can help when you look at
the assumptions of the free energy
principle that are super generic.
So you can view all these algorithms as
specific implementations of active
inference in a way that active inference
is meant to scale well.
So this is kind of like the thing.
And so I think ultimately, again, these
two Fields are going to converge, but I
do not see any tension between them.
It's more like the tools from one can be
used in the other.
I see great work going forward.
And this is kind of like what we want to
do with this paper.
Put this active coherence where it comes
from very succinctly, and also make it
accessible for people who don't know the
jargon from the fringe principal and
active coherence community.
And yes, see the exciting developments
that will follow.
Daniel: Wow.
Great comments.
Two things that reflects to me the
constraints that you mentioned, which we
sometimes call the particular partition
essentially cleaving the particle, which
you show in figure two, cleaving the
particle off from the environment.
This is something that's widely applied
in agent based modeling.
Just anytime you're talking about some
field of action and a player, we're
basically at least qualitatively within
the space of partitioning agents from
environments and then further saying,
well, there's no edge between the
internal and the external states, so
there's no telepathy and there's no
telekinesis and incoming information.
We're going to call sense outgoing.
We're going to call action that
qualitatively and formally is basically
consistent with almost any cybernetics
formulation of adaptive action.
So Axel constant are really quite minimal
and seemingly being generalized year
after year with the work so many
colleagues are involved in.
So Axel Costa are not onerous.
And I think it's a really interesting
question which reinforcement learnings
are compatible?
And then coming from the other side, in a
lot of active modeling contexts, we find
ourselves sometimes proposing like
auxiliary variables.
Like, let's just do a parameter sweep
over this.
And then we'll look back to the textbook
or to the paper.
We think, well, where was that in
expected free energy?
We just proposed this random thing.
Where was that in the equation?
Or we'll look at step by step guide to
active inference where it's all written
in terms of matrices.
It's all very read.
It like a sentence.
And all of a sudden it's like, wait a
could be a neural network.
It doesn't just have to be a matrix.
So it's kind of like we bring in these
methods and ingredients that are being
used widely, empirically.
And these are the two approaches.
Do we build the bottom up mosaic of
approaches stopping when it works?
And or do we start with this most general
agent based cybernetic formulation and
then kind of build the castle in the sky
and meet in the middle again with
something that works?
It's just incredibly laid out.
And this paper is at that saddle point
because it has one hand or antenna or
whatever in this smooth information
geometry conceptual area.
But the motivator of all of the
conceptual moves that are made, which
honestly are extensive, like page after
page, it was just like, where's it
going?
It's going somewhere that can be
simulated on everyday hardware.
So many of the moves were about reshaping
or reframing what was to be done in a way
that could be simulated.
And so those two paths are connecting and
like you said, there's not necessarily
attention, but it'll be quite interesting
to see how this develops on the theory,
practice and social frontiers as more and
more of these threads start to combine.
Lance: Yeah, I agree.
I think it's particularly beautiful when
theory meets practice.
You oftentimes have practice that works,
but you have no theory or you have a
theory that's beautiful but that doesn't
work in practice.
And this just happens all the time.
Typically you would have active that
works and then you would try to build a
theory out of it, but then often the
theory turns out to be too hard, so you
make some extra assumptions and so on.
You end up with a theory, but the theory
turns out to be quite removed from the
practice.
So you kind of get that gap.
It's very beautiful and quite unique and
also quite rare when the theory meets the
practice.
And I would say when the theory meets the
practice and in particular meets the
state of the art, then you kind of have a
complete theory.
So what we wanted to do in this paper is
review these different Fields in a way
that we could show how far the community
has gone between making a theory that
meets the state of the art.
And every section was started with
theoretical considerations about what
should be when you need to solve a
particular problem, let's say adaptive
agents or sampling or optimization.
And then from there, and from logical
steps about, okay, well, it should be
like this and not like that, because
there is whatever kind of geometric
argument or other arguments.
And so from there, logically arriving at
state of the art methods that are used in
practice.
The other kind of like sequence of
logical steps was, okay, well, we're
going to start with optimization which is
in my view, at the root of everything.
So sampling could be about optimizing
samples to obtain the best approximation
to your integral inferences about
optimizing beliefs and decision making.
It's about optimizing decisions based on
their counterfactuals consequences.
So we started up with optimization
because it's the simplest thing both
conceptually and also in terms of use
case you need optimization to do
everything else.
We then went to sampling and to inference
and finally to decision making because it
just brings all these three ingredients
together.
We didn't go as far as showing, okay,
well, this is how you should scale active
inference in order to solve all the
problems in the world because this just
hasn't been done right.
But we listed a few ingredients that have
gone into the literature and also a few
ingredients that this perspective offers
to how to scale active inference and make
it more effective.
So it's actually future work and open
problem to use the techniques that have
been developed in the sampling section
and the sampling literature to make
active inference even more scalable and
same with optimization and same with
coherence.
So there's many things that have been put
forward in this article and also
elsewhere that can be used to scale
active imprints but ant least.
Yeah, the goal was to be as comprehensive
as possible without sacrificing too much
of actually understanding what's really
going on and show how the theory means to
practice throughout and really where the
field stands.
Daniel: So one kind of reflection on
this, again, is if we start with reward
as our basal imperative pragmatism.
I mean, after all, don't we want to get
things done, achieve results in the
world, realize our preferences?
We start with pragmatism and then it is
empirically ad hoc how people introduce
these novelty bonus or intrinsic
motivations.
In contrast, we can start with this
information gain approach and then the
thumb is put on the scale to bring more
and more emphasis onto the alignment with
preference.
So it's like two roads, two paths.
And maybe this is our bias or corner of
the information space that starting with
a broader epistemic imperative allows the
careful introduction of pragmatic value
whereas a pragmatic foundation that it's
hard to then recast epistemic value in
terms of pragmatic value.
That's kind of like the question of
valuing basic research.
And the approach taken here is develop an
imperative that can look entirely like
one or the other or mixtures.
But what's always so perplexing is that
it has this extrinsic and intrinsic value
phrasing but there are other ways to
decompose the function.
So even intrinsic and extrinsic value are
not necessarily the ingredients that were
put in.
It's more like they were two ingredients
that were split out of something else
that is much more integrated.
It wasn't like the free energy was
constructed by composition of any given
decomposition of which there are multiple
for variational free energy and expected
free energy.
So then a question that I've often
wondered is there might be two policies
that are very close or have essentially
identical expected free energy but they
could be radically different.
For example, one could be having a good
expected free energy because it realizes
a lot of preferences.
Another might because it provides a lot
of information gain.
So is it really as simple asterisk
asterisk as a unified imperative or how
do we make sense of the fact that one
value could rank policies that might
have, for example, extremely different
danger profiles or envelopes of
outcomes?
How can that seemingly multidimensional
space be projected into essentially a
ranking?
Lance: Yeah, it's a complicated
question.
As we can see, the expected free energy
does this in some way.
It provides an answer to this question
based on your preferences and how much
you would gain by observing this new
data, how much information you would
gain.
You can put these two things on the
same.
Footing.
This is what expected PNG does, and it
gives you a ranking.
You're right to say that two very
different courses of action could have
the same expected free energy.
And so how do you choose between them?
Well, the standard formulation that you
would see in textbooks or papers has,
okay, well, G of Action Sequence equals
this and G of Sequence equals that.
So these two Action sequences have the
same G and you don't know what to do.
But here, this theoretical development in
this paper makes it very clear that the
expected PNG is a minus lock
probability.
And this is why.
So to make it more transparent, instead
of using the letter G that's commonly
used in the literature, we kept the minus
log P throughout.
So we never used the letter G.
And so the expected free energy is this
minus log P of Action Sequence.
And so it says, okay, well, if two Action
Sequences have the same expected free
energy, well, then you have, let's say
you just have two of them with the same
expected force energy, the lowest one,
well, then you choose probabilistically.
Like half of the time you choose one, and
half of the time you use the other.
Actually, it's even a bit more
complicated because since it's a minus
lot P, you could have an Action Sequence
with a very high expected free energy.
And so this means that you can still take
it.
But if you would take it, like, not very
often.
So you have an exponentially low chance
of taking that Action Sequence.
So it's a probabilistic description.
It says that the most likely Action
Sequence would be the argument, the
minimum of the expected free energy.
So this is like the top line in the
figure.
And so if you have two most likely Action
Sequences, well, then you choose like
half of the time you choose one, half of
the time you choose the other.
But then in general, if you didn't want
to simulate the most likely Action
Sequence, then you choose
probabilistically between all of them.
And the Action Sequences that have the
lowest expected reality has an
exponentially higher chance of being
selected and the others don't.
One last thing.
Another very nice perspective is that the
probability over Action sequences, so
these P of a greater than equal to T is
then the exponential of minus the
expected free energy.
Because if you take exponential minus of
what you get in the equality on the left,
then you recover this probability
distribution of our Action Sequences.
So this distribution of our Action
Sequences is exponential minus expected
free energy, exponential minus what's in
there.
And we saw before, that gives measures,
they arise everywhere.
And so this is an example of a gives
measure.
You have exponential minus something
basically, based on the formalism of the
free free energy principle comes up that
the probability distribution over Actions
is a gives measure.
It is the gives measure where what's
inside is the expected free energy.
So, yeah, it's kind of like a full circle
thing and this is basically this sort of
like connectivity.
They just happen all the time when we
were writing this paper and discussing
because there's so many things that just
there's so many crossovers at so many
different levels.
Like on the sort of object level that
you're studying, but also on the
ecological level, like methodologies that
are used in some field, they're used in a
different field to do something else.
So there's so many crossovers.
And so this is, I would say, an
interesting example of why gives
measures, gives distinctions, they just
arise everywhere.
They arise active inference Lab and as we
saw before, they're hard to sample from.
So if you wanted to so let's say you have
your gives distribution that says, okay,
well, this is my distribution of our
action sequences that I get from the
expected free energy.
Then you have two choices.
Either you sample from it to sample like
an average, I would say not a typical
action sequence, or you could optimize
the distribution or optimize the expected
free energy to sample the most likely
action sequence.
In the two cases after you've done your
planning with the expected free energy,
you have a choice between sampling and
optimization.
So you kind of go back full circle of
like if I want to select my action gain,
I either select the most likely action by
optimizing the expected free energy or
the gives measure by optimizing this
minus lot P by taking the action sequence
with the minimal expected free energy.
Or I have my gives measure and it will
sample from it to like get a typical
action sequence.
So it's all like super interrelated.
Daniel: Very interesting in the Par et
al.
Textbook from 2022, that dialectic is
mapped onto the mammalian nervous system
where policies can be selected by
essentially passing through habit
proportionally or expected free energy
can be applied to sharpen or optimize the
posterior on action.
Does this influence how you select micro
meso or macro actions?
Lance: Do you mean for human being
like actions at the cellular level,
actions at the Global level?
Or is it something different like at.
Daniel: The personal, grasping a coffee
cup at the micro, larger scale decisions,
attention allocation, communication
emissions.
Lance: Yeah, I think all of these
things can be formulated in this
treatment.
So, for example, attention would be where
you choose to place your focus or your
mental eye, so to speak.
So that's and internal action, it could
be unconscious, it could be undirected,
but still happening.
I'm not an expert, but there's a lot of
talking consciousness research of like,
you being conscious.
There's a very low amount of processes
that are conscious and these change
according to where you're inner eye or
your conscious eye, whatever you want to
call it, like moves.
This could be thought of a mental action
or an inner action that you may or may
not control, but still and action.
So all these, all other action, whether
it is planning at the short time scale,
taking a coffee cup standing, or planning
at the longer time scale, like what am I
going to do after my PhD and so on, all
of these things are action.
So typically, as you know, of course, we
we model that by using hierarchical
models where you have different levels in
your giant model.
So in your model of the world and the
higher levels are represent more abstract
representations and also longer time
scales.
So it could be, let's say at some higher
level I'm going to take the plane to go
to Amsterdam, for example, and at the
lower level, okay, well, once in
Amsterdam, I'm going to do this, this and
this.
It's like this action at the higher level
of taking the plane predates everything
that you're going to do at the lower
level.
And so factorizing these different
decisions into different levels of a
model allow you to be completionally,
practical, practically implementable when
you make those decisions.
And presumably this is why we do in our
everyday life factorize decisions and
representations into low level and high
level things.
The beauty of the free energy principle
and of the treatment here.
But the treatment here is again, just the
free energy principle in its most bare
bones and general form is that the
expected free energy is formulated for
any kind of gentle model.
The gentle models that you have in the
figure on the bottom right there, they
could be arbitrary.
So you could use this form of expected
Lagrange for hierarchical generative
models that have all these like high
level, low level decisions and
representations, but you could also use
it for any other kind of generative
model.
The only difference is that with some
world models, it would be very hard to
implement this in practice and with other
world models, and in particular those
that are highly factorised and
distributed like hierarchical models,
like the wounds we just talked about.
With these it would typically Dean much
simpler to take decisions that minimize
expected frequency when it comes to
practical computation, just because when
you action oriented representation
things, just computations just factor out
a lot and it's just like way simpler to
do.
But the formulation here is like entirely
generic and it could apply to all kinds
of models and all kinds of situations.
Daniel: Very interesting.
Well, in our last little segment on the
dot one, let's hear your perspective or
overview on the roadmap.
Just walk through what the sections are
and you mentioned some related topics,
but what do the subjects broadly cover?
Why are they structured in that order?
Lance: Right, well, first of all, the
introduction just puts like everything in
context, the conducting line or one of
the common points between all of these
sections is that there's a lot of
geometry.
So this was not purely because the
journal is like the handbook of
statistics, it was called Geometry and
Statistics.
So this is not just for that, but it's
because geometry just comes up naturally
in all these places.
So this is what we explained in the
introduction, like how geometry comes up,
the different branches of geometry that
come up in this different field and how
they're interrelated.
And so just from there you kind of get a
picture of, okay, well, this branch,
let's say symplectic geometry, for
example, it comes up in accelerated
optimization and it also comes up in
sampling.
And so you can already see from there
what is going to be discussed, of course,
but also which branches of geometry occur
where and what kind of parallels there
are already.
So going from the introduction to
accelerated optimization.
So optimization is conceptually, it's a
very simple thing.
It's like, okay, we have a function.
So coming back to, let's say that my Dean
state space come back to where we started
with and you have a function and a
landscape over it, let's say like a
mountain.
And so the goal is to find the minimum of
the mountain.
I go from where you start to the
minimum.
There's so many different ways of solving
this problem, practically speaking.
The main challenge, of course, is that
you don't know, you cannot speak anywhere
else except where you have been.
So you start somewhere and you're
completely blind and you need to find a
minimum.
So how do you do that?
There's so many ways, so many approaches
to optimization.
I mean, it's a whole field and it's in my
opinion, a very messy one.
And this is understandable because
there's no free lunch theorems that are
very well known that say that under some
hypotheses, two ways of doing
optimization will behave the same on
average if you test them again, all
possible sorts of problems.
So this is to say that if you have a
given problem, then you need to give then
the optimization methods that will work
well are those that implicitly use the
prior information that you have about the
problem.
In other words, according to the
theorems, there's no optimization methods
that will beat everything, it just
doesn't exist because they're all on
average the same.
But this is not to say that you cannot
make any practical, meaningful steps by
doing optimization because not all
optimization problems are the
optimization problems that we have in
life.
They're not completely random, they're
not completely random landscapes that we
need to optimize, but they actually have
some structure.
So we can actually explore that in
algorithms and have things that just
behave, that just work a lot better for
the type of problems that we're
interested in than others.
So this is what kind of like the starting
point for all optimization.
The type of optimization that we
considered here is optimization of smooth
functions.
This is already like a big restriction
there's.
So many methods that are designed to
optimize functions that are rugged or non
smooth or have discontinuities and so
on.
When you actually get rugged or
discontinuous landscapes, it's a whole
different problem.
Here we chose to focus on smooth
functions.
The idea is that you have a smooth
landscape, you want to find the minimum.
And one way to do so, and to do so well,
is through the use of a tool called
geometric inclination.
So I'll walk through the main ideas of
this section.
The idea, first of all, is that you may
design a method that theoretically works
very well, but when you implement it in
practice on your computer, your
discretion errors, because you can only
implement it in discrete time, what you
actually end up implementing ends up
deferring significantly from what you
initially wanted to implement.
This is a problem that we discussed
previously in sampling and it just comes
up everywhere in applied mathematics and
numerical mathematics.
The fact that you can only do discrete
computations on your computer is a big
implication and it's something that needs
to be looked into.
It's maybe even the most important thing
that needs to be looked into.
When building a numerical method, you
want to be able to implement numerical
methods that are very close from what you
theoretically would like to implement.
So typically you would have some
theoretical algorithm that would have
some convergence guarantees or
performance guarantees.
And so you would like to wait a way to
implement it on your computer so as to
preserve those guarantees.
And this turns out to be very hard in
general.
One way to do it, I would say maybe the
most powerful way out there to do this is
through procedures from the field of
geometric inclination.
And so geometric integration is a set of
techniques that allow you under certain
cognition to discretize your theoretical,
dynamic or theoretical optimization
procedure like dynamical system, and make
it into an algorithm that you can
practically implement on a computer.
And that's going to respect the
performance guarantees that you already
have.
So now the tricky part, geometric
inclination is based on geometry.
So you need to find it's not as simple as
like, okay, well, I have my landscape, my
function landscape, and I'd like to just
go down and find the minimum.
One way to do that is just by doing grain
in descent in continuous time.
And you know that that's going to go down
until it reaches a local minimum at the
very least.
So it's not too bad.
If you were to implement gradient descent
numerically, it wouldn't be exactly the
same as like the continuous time
dynamic.
It could be that actually by implementing
gradient descent numerically, you get all
sorts of numerical problems or whatnot
maybe grade and send.
It's so simple it's not actually a good
example.
But the point I want to make is that it's
not as simple as like, okay, well, I have
this dynamic that works really well, and
that gets to the minimum.
And I know that it's going to get to the
minimum this fast.
And so geometric integration will give me
an algorithm that I can implement on my
computer, and that's going to get to the
minimum this fast as well.
It's not as simple as this.
Geometric integration works by preserving
geometric structures in the dynamic that
you started with.
So in order to be able to apply geometric
integration, to have algorithms that work
for optimization, you need to design a
dynamical system that converges to the
minimum and that has some important
geometric features that can be preserved
in this way.
And so this is basically the goal of the
whole section, and it goes into the
following steps.
So one thing that can be discretized or
implemented on a computer in a way that
is close to the true dynamical system is
what's called Hamiltonian flows.
So if you specify a Hamiltonian, which is
a kinetic energy and potential energy,
then you get the Hamilton Jacobi
equations of motion that gives you the
behavior of the system that has the
prescribed Hamiltonian.
So for those who've taken a course in
physics, you probably know or may have
seen that all of Newtonian mechanics can
be reformulated as Hamiltonian
mechanics.
So all of that can be described as with
Newton, lows of motion can be described
through Hamiltonian mechanics.
It's a very general framework or a very
general way to look at physics, because
it's such a general point of view on
physics and such a, and just
Hamiltonians, they come up everywhere,
this mixture of kinetic and potential
energy, to concisely summarize the
behavior of a system.
Because they occur so much, they have
been studied extensively, and it turns
out that Hamiltonians and specifically
the motion they entail.
So the Hamilton Jacobi equations of
motion, they can be discretized or
implemented accurately on a computer
using Symplectic integration, which is a
part of geometric integration.
So in short, you can use Symplectic
integration to accurately simulate a
Hamiltonian dynamical system.
Now, the problem is, these dynamics are
conservative, so they preserve the
Hamiltonian.
So if you're at some point hidden states,
space with a certain kinetic energy,
potential energy, and you run the
dynamics forward, your overall energy is
not going to change.
So that standard physics.
Energy is always conserved when there's
no friction, all kind of like ideal
physical systems with no friction, the
energy is conserved.
So when you're going to run this
Symplectic optimization scheme to
simulate these Hamilton and Jacobi
equations of motion, the energy is going
to be conserved.
Now, we're in trouble if we want to do
optimization, because in optimization, if
you think of the function as the energy,
you want to dissipate energy as much as
possible to reach the minimum.
So you want to lose energy.
So what the section does so this section,
by the Way, is a review of more technical
papers what these papers do, it's a very
clever trick is they say, okay, well, we
want to minimize a function.
We're going to say the function is
potential energy and also we're going to
add a kinetic energy on top of that to
get a Hamiltonian.
Now this Hamiltonian, we could simulate
it through symplectic integration, but
actually, if we did, we wouldn't
dissipate the function.
So now what the section does is it
introduces a higher dimensional state
space with the Hamiltonian that if you
simulate those dynamics, it actually
optimizes the function.
So this is what was a convoluted way to
say it reformulates optimization as a
conservative system with a different
Hamiltonian.
And so by and because we know how to
simulate dynamics with Hamiltonian so
well, a good way of doing optimization is
by finding a Hamiltonian so that when you
discretize it, you get the optimization
process that you wanted.
If you do that, you get a numerical
method that's stable, that works well,
that has good coherence guarantees.
And it turns out the numerical methods
that are developed, they work for
optimization on any kind of smooth
manifold, for function, on any smooth
functions, on any smooth manifold.
They work well.
They are generalized gradient descent in
the sense that you recover gradient
descent in a certain limit.
And they can be seen as accelerated
because they have this notion of
acceleration in the sense that, let's say
the function that you want to optimize,
it like a hill and you want to go down.
If you just did great, in the sense
you're like blindingly going down at the
same speed, or your speed is like
proportional to the slope of the
landscape.
But when you actually let a Bull rolling
down, this is not really what happens.
The Bull is going to roll faster and
faster and it's going to accelerate, it's
going to go down, it's going to overshoot
the minimum and then it's going to like
oscillate until it converges to a
minimum.
So these are the kind of optimization
methods that are developed here.
They're optimization methods that are
accelerated in a physical sense, that has
physical sense acceleration and physical
meaning because they're going to
accelerate as they go down, overshoot and
then stabilize.
So this is the whole point of this
section.
Now briefly, because I think we're
running out of time, but we can of
course, revisit these sections later.
In the third action.
We have sampling.
So we talked extensively about sampling.
The sampling, as we discussed, can be
seen as an optimization of probability
distributions.
So we have the distribution that we want
to sample from, and we just run a process
that is random so it can be described by
its own distribution and want the process
to concept as fast as possible to the
target.
So we want that distribution of the
process to concept as fast as possible to
the target distinctions.
So in a way that can be seen as I guess
complicated for many people.
I think it's pretty abstract.
But it's been known for a long time that
you can reformulate sampling as just
optimization of distributions.
Now it turns out that when you use the
accelerated optimization method of the
second section to sampling so when you
use, when you do accelerated optimization
on the space of probability distributions
in order to solve the sampling problem,
you get a process that's called under
damp launch one dynamics.
So if you solve that process, you're
basically going to get good samples, very
good samples of your target distribution
because that process can be seen as doing
an accelerated optimization on the space
of probability distributions.
In other words, the distribution
describing the process is going to
accelerate towards the target.
So you're going to get there very fast
and your symbols are going to be very
good.
So this is 2.6 where this is kind of
derived.
In 3.1, we basically talk about the the
good properties of samplers in general.
So sampling is not like a complete field,
but there's a lot of work showing that
certain processes have certain
characteristics of processes make them
better samplers and others make them
worse.
So this is what we discuss.
And then in free .2, we put this all
together in Hamiltonian Monte Carlo,
which is a state of the art method for
sampling.
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo is a way of
using, if you use symplectic integration
under Downplantromodynamics, which is
your accelerated sampling method, that
you cannot stimulate directly, again, you
get the same problem.
If you use symplectic integration to
simulate that, then you get HamiltonI
Monte Carlo.
So Hamiltonian Monte Carlo is attributes
Google way of doing accelerated sampling
that's based on ideas of symplectic
integration.
Now, very briefly, the section four is on
inference.
The inference in its most general form is
variational inference.
So what we typically do know and love
from active inference.
And I have a target probability
distribution that I'm not able to compute
directly.
So I'm going to approximate it as best as
I can.
Now, these distributions, they're often
used to compute expectations, or in other
words, in statistics and machine
learning, we often need to compute
expectations with respect to some
probability distribution.
What this section does is it derives a
whole bunch of divergences.
Like the Kel divergence.
I mean, the Kale divergence is not
discussed so much in this action.
I'll explain why, but it derives a whole
bunch of divergences that can be used to
approximate this unknown distribution
with some other distributions that are
tractable.
So to put in a different way, you have
this abstract variational inference
problem where you have this target
distribution and then you have this
family of distribution that you know, and
you want to select the distribution in
your family that best approximates your
target distribution.
Now, in order to do this, you first need
to derive a measure of similarity between
distributions to know, okay, well, what
is the best distribution.
Like, how can you quantify being the best
distribution, being the best
approximation to your target
distribution?
And to do that, you need to specify a
emergence, like the KL divergence.
But the problem is, the KL divergence is
not always practically applicable.
One example is when the target
distribution is just given by samples.
So maybe you don't even know the target
distribution.
Maybe it's a gaussian, but you don't know
it.
You just have samples from the gaussian.
So you cannot just have, like, a
histogram, and you need to best
approximate the histogram with the
distribution in some family.
So when you have a problem like this,
which just happens all the time, you
cannot use the KL divergence.
So you need to think about other
divergences.
And so what this section does is deriving
other classes of divergences that are
more generally applicable than the KL
divergence, and they have also some very
nice properties and then showing, okay,
well, how is it that I can minimize these
divergences to solve a variation of
inference problem?
So I think there's a lot of things to be
done there in the sense that in active
inference, we always use the Kale
divergence to do variational inference
and minimize free energy.
And this Kale divergence is available
because we typically have adjuncted
models that are nice and they're
expressed graphical models.
But there's this whole other plethora of
divergences and algorithms to minimize
the divergences that's out there.
And it could be the case that there's
very interesting recipes and methods that
can be either brought back to the KL case
that we use or just used altogether in
our setting.
In particular, when, for example, let's
say they wanted to approximate the
expected free energy in active coherence,
the expected free energy is an
expectation and want to approximate that
expectation.
It could be the case.
Well, I think these methods that are
summarizing section four could be very
useful because they basically develop
divergences that quantify how far the
expectations are going to be if you
choose a different distribution.
So it's all like, very natural in that
computational sense.
And then finally ant activation through
active coherence.
Well, I think we've discussed that
already extensively, but I won't spoil it
more today and we can come back to it
next time.
Daniel: Thanks a lot for that overview.
That was very powerful.
Incredible dot one very informative.
Looking forward to starting with some
questions from the live chaos and
people's comments on the video between
now and next week.
If anybody else of your colleagues or
anyone in the institute wants to join,
we'll be here next week for 52.2.
So thank you, Lance, for the time.
Really appreciate it.
Lance: Thanks, Daniel.
Daniel: Farewell.
Lance: See you next week.
Bye.